und bleiben in berlin und dort steht
schon mein kollege erhard scherfer es
geht nämlich heute im bundestag um die
befragung der bundesregierung und
insbesondere heute befragung des
bundeskanzlers nämlich immer vor ostern
vor der sommerpause und vor weihnachten
ist der kanzler dran und muss seine
politik erklären was wird denn dort
heute eine rolle spielen herr schärfer
ist es dann nur die ukraine oder wird
das dann auch noch mal eben zum beispiel
das was karl lauterbach angesprochen hat
könnte das auch noch eine rolle spielen
ich sags mal so bernd rasen wir haben
120 tage ampelkoalitionen das heißt wir
haben auch 120 tage bundeskanzler
scholze hat sich schon das eine oder
andere thema angesammelt in diesen in
diesen monaten nicht nur ukraine sondern
beispielsweise auch die impfpflicht die
hier morgen abschließend beraten werden
wird und wo es in den vergangenen tagen
jedoch noch einiges an bewegung gegeben
hat aber im mittelpunkt mutmaßlich heute
haben wir ja immerhin 42 tage lang krieg
gegen die ukraine wir haben 39 tage der
sogenannten zeitenwende die der
bundeskanzler ausgerufen hat am 27
februar hier in der sondersitzung des
bundestags und heute steht er nun den
abgeordneten zum zweiten mal in diesem
jahr rhede und hoffentlich auch antwort
und wir werfen vorab aber schon mal
einen blick auf diese sogenannte
zeitenwende und ihre folgen und das tun
wir mit nils schmid dem außenpolitischen
sprecher der spd-fraktion ihnen einen
schönen guten tag und ich begrüße
johann war doch wohl fragen sie mich
jetzt nicht warum ich da jetzt
gestolpert bin johann wadephul ist der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unions-fraktion und zuständig und gut im
bild zu den themen außen- sicherheits-
und verteidigungspolitik auch ihnen
schöntag ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch
wieder ich werde normalerweise sage ich
hier guten morgen das funktioniert um
diese zeit aber nicht wären wir wieder
ernst und der situation angemessen eine
zeitenwende das stichwort habe ich schon
genannt wie viel hat herr schmid die
koalition wie viel hat aber auch die
bundesregierung bislang dafür getan um
dieser zeitenwende gerecht zu werden
eine menge also wir haben ja den
bundeshaushalt er in vorbereitung ist
die grundgesetzänderung für das
sondervermögen 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr ist in vorbereitung wir
werden also in den nächsten wochen
dieses sondervermögen beschließen und
damit die bundeswehr besser ausrüsten
wir haben in der nato besprochen dass
auch die bundeswehr sich an der schutz
der in dem schutz der ostflanke im
baltikum in anderen östlichen nato
staaten beteiligt und vor allem haben
wir mit waffenlieferungen die ukraine in
die lage versetzt besser gegen den
russischen einzel vorzugehen das ist
gute mannschaften stichworte trinke ich
hier sowieso auf meinem zettel aber die
werden wir gleich mal vertiefen herr
wadephul was wollen sie heute wissen vom
bundeskanzler ja überhaupt das einmal
wieder stellung nimmt gegenüber dem
deutschen bundestag hat eine große rede
gehalten am 27 februar danach erscheint
er hier nicht allzu häufig
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat nahezu zu
jedem eu-gipfel eine regierungserklärung
gehalten wir haben jetzt einen neuen
traurigen schrecklichen höhepunkt des
ukraine krieges mit den wasserkern
butscher und ich hatte mir eigentlich
auch gewünscht dass der bundeskanzler
dazu morgen auch im deutschen bundestag
in form einer regierungserklärung das
wort ergreift aber wir werden ihn jetzt
dazu fragen in der tat das ist
bemerkenswert der kollege schmid hat
gesagt die bundesregierung hat die
zeitenwende eingeläutet das ist ganz was
anderes als was im koalitionsvertrag
drin stand was man sich vorgenommen
hatte aber in der tat man hat eine
anpassung vorgenommen die union
unterstützt das im prinzip aber wir
wollen natürlich jetzt auch einzelheiten
wissen was geschieht konkret und damit
die ukraine sich wirklich wirkungsvoll
verteidigen kann wir werden auch auf
diesen punkt noch mal gucken ein ganz
wichtiger diskussion in den vergangenen
tagen ist unter anderem gewesen dass
viele ehemalige spd minister in amt und
würden oder auch jetzt der jetzige
bundespräsident sich geäußert haben zu
russland politik auch die
mecklenburg-vorpommersche
ministerpräsidentin schwesig hat fehler
eingeräumt der bundespräsident auch in
der russland politik wer herr schmid
muss ich noch alles äußern in dieser
klarheit ich glaube alle in deutschland
die in den letzten jahren verantwortung
getragen haben auch kanzlerin merkel zum
beispiel
haben die russlandpolitik zu
verantworten und man sollte sich auch
nicht täuschen es waren damals auch
andere umstände und man hat damals nach
besten wissen und gewissen gehandelt ich
würde das niemandem absprechen weder
frau merkel noch von walter steinmeier
umso wichtiger ist es dass man dann auch
entschlossen umsteuert nachdem das
bisherige verhältnis zu russland durch
putin zerstört worden ist und
entsprechend ist es gut dass olaf scholz
gehandelt hat sigmar gabriel und heiko
maas uns jetzt nicht erwähnt die beiden
außenminister der letzten beiden
legislaturperioden gehe ja auch
unterschiedlichen umgang gepflegt haben
mit russland und mit wladimir putin ja
aber ich finde jetzt nicht dass
sozusagen jeder sich äußern muss ich
finde es gut wenn bundespräsident
steinmeier ist tut entscheidend ist das
handeln der jetzigen regierung und da
hat scholz und klaren kurs vorgegeben
den wir auch in der breite der koalition
unterstützen aber so ein bisschen
aufarbeitung und noch mal sagen warum
haben wir so entschieden
was zu dieser heutigen situation auch
mit geführt haben könnte zumindest gerd
schröder würde ich auch gerne mal hören
beispielsweise er den wirt mehr hin und
wieder
aber
ich glaube entscheiden ist wirklich dass
wir aus der erfahrung unserer beziehung
zu russland lernen für den umgang mit
anderen autoritären regimen wir wissen
ja nicht wie sich das verhältnis zu
china beispielsweise weiterentwickelt
und die herausforderung durch china
technologisch ökonomisch aber auch
sicherheitspolitisch ist noch von einer
anderen dimension als die von russland
wir wissen dass handel durch wandel
durch handel im verhältnis zu russland
immer weniger gebracht hat zuletzt gar
nichts mehr und entsprechende fragen
müssen wir uns auch in fällen zu china
stellen und daraus die schlussfolgerung
zu ziehen ich glaube das ist jetzt die
aufgabe also aus der vergangenheit
lernen für den umgang mit anderen
herausforderungen wie zum beispiel china
wenn herr vogel hören wir noch mal was
von der alt kanzlerin zu diesem thema
unter ihrer rolle und ihren gedanken die
sie sich zu jener zeit gemacht hat denn
es ist ja durchaus was dran an dem was
herr schmid sagt denkt wir haben wir
sind von anderen voraussetzungen
ausgegangen aber die kann man ja
trotzdem erklären ja natürlich
das wird die kanzlerin selber
entscheiden wann und wie sie sich
äußerst dann würden sie gerne mal hören
sondern natürlich also ich habe
vergangenen tagen die bitte geäußert
dass der bundespräsident sich äußert
wahrscheinlich auf mich reagiert aber er
hat sich gefangen ukrainische
botschafter ja der hat ihn sehr stark
angegriffen ich bin insgesamt ja meinung
wir sollten schon auf arbeiten als
deutscher bundestag ra ich kann mir
vorstellen dass wir eine ranke
kommission zu dieser frage mal einsetzen
weil in der tat da stimme ich dem
kollegen schmidt zu ich finde alle haben
an dass das aufzuarbeiten
wir sind aber auch von anderen annahme
ausgegangen und die frage ist ja was
lernt man aus fehlern das ist ja im
normalen leben so und dass es auch im
politischen leben so wir haben übrigens
noch zwei fraktionen ganz links ganz
rechts die heute noch nichts darüber
davon lernen wollen und auch ein
unkritisches verhältnis auch zu russland
nach wie vor haben also darüber wir
haben auch hier übrigens autokorsos in
berlin mit russischen flecken in zeiten
wo wir das massaker von butscher
gewärtigen müssen also wir haben in
deutschland schon insgesamt einiges
aufzuarbeiten
ich nehme für uns in anspruch dass wir
seit 2014 schon manches gelernt haben
wir sind 42 prozent eingetreten eine
stärkere bundeswehr das war in der
großen koalition noch nicht durchsetzbar
jetzt will des bundeskanzlers scholz
also die deutsche politik ist glaube ich
insgesamt lernfähig aber wir müssen uns
dafür auch zeit nehmen also 542
irgendwie um besser einfach nur noch mal
zu platzieren doch jede menge
befürworter in der union und
selbstverständlich außerhalb jeder frage
wir haben das unterstützt ich zähle mich
selber auch dazu das ist vollkommen klar
wir haben schon gedacht dass wenn man es
wenn es vernünftige
wirtschaftsbeziehungen gibt dass es die
möglichkeit gibt auch in einigen
politischen grundfragen auch zu
verständigungen zu kommen mindestens zum
ausschluss von krieg aber daran haben
wir uns definitiv gehört und das muss
geklärt werden darüber muss man sich
auch fragen stellen was heißt dass der
kollege schmidt recht was heißt das für
china das heißt das für den für den
umgang mit anderen totalitären regime
die wir auch der welt ja auch noch
bedauerlicherweise haben haben wir bei
der früheren großen koalition so ein
bisschen die situation mitgehangen
mitgefangen aber schauen wir nach vorne
das was sie beide ja auch reklamiert
haben schauen wir auf dieses 100
milliarden sogenannte sondervermögen ich
sage mal gerne sondern schuld weil es
vermögen das hat man irgendwie aber das
soll ja ausgegeben werden insofern bin
ich mit dem begriff nicht so ganz im
reinen auch wenn das haushaltstechnisch
tatsächlich so heißt diese 100
milliarden wird seitens der union
gelegentlich bezweifelt ob die
tatsächlichen die richtung ausgegeben
werden und dafür ausgegeben werden wofür
sie aus sicht der union zumindest
ausgegeben werden sollen wie wird das
verfahren sein herr schmidt gibt es ja
schon ein bisschen mehr erkenntnisse
darüber weil die und die union fordert
ein mitspracherecht ein wenn sie das mit
verabschieden soll weil eine
grundgesetzänderung nötig ist helfen sie
uns ein bisschen also selbstverständlich
wird die union mit einbezogen aber wir
wollen ja gemeinsam das grundgesetz
ändern und ich meine zunächst mal müssen
wir den text definieren der dieser
grundgesetzänderung zu grunde liegen
soll das heißt über den text wird auch
die zweckbestimmung dieser
sondervermögens genau festgelegt und für
uns ist klar es geht um die bundeswehr
um die stärkung der
verteidigungsfähigkeit und dann werden
wir jährlich im haushalt festlegen wie
viel aus dem sondervermögen entnommen
werden muss für bestimmte
rüstungsprojekte
das kann naturgemäß
noch nicht so konkret seien vielleicht
für die haushaltsjahre 22 22 sehr
konkret für die folgejahre brauchen wir
da auch eine gewisse flexibilität aber
ich glaube wir werden uns damit union
einig denn wir haben das gemeinsame ziel
dass die ausstattung der bundeswehr
massiv verbessert werden muss da haben
wir nachholbedarf da gehen sie mit da
gehe ich auch mit dem verfahren also dem
kollegen schmidt nämlich ab dass wir
beteiligt werden nur bis heute geschieht
es nicht dass es etwas bedauerlich das
müsst ihr nur noch langsam geschehen wir
sprechen in der tat über den
verfassungstext jetzt wir wollen
eigenartige rolle für die union als
opposition nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als dass die aussage von bundeskanzler
scholz erstens 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr 22 prozent ab jetzt und
dauerhaft dass diese aussagen umgesetzt
werden wenn das geschieht dann sind wir
im boot ich habe keinen zweifel dass die
spd das etwas in ihrer ganz übergroßen
mehrheit will bei den grünen habe ich
zweifel das muss innerhalb der ampel
geklärt werden aber wir sind da
konstruktiv wir setzen in diesen fragen
nicht auf fundamental opposition wir
beteiligen uns wir haben eigene
vorstellungen dazu wie das in der
bundeswehr verwendet werden sollte aber
wir wissen auch wir regieren jetzt nicht
und wenn diese mindestbedingungen
umgesetzt werden dann werden wir uns
daran konstruktiv beteiligen gucken wir
auf der zwei punkte wenigstens die
kürzung noch thematisiert kriegen die im
moment in dieser diskussion eine große
rolle spielen das eine ist dass energie
embargo gegenüber russland herr schmidt
wie lange wollen sie das noch
durchhalten weiter gas und auch öl aus
russland zu importieren nach deutschland
bei kohle scheint es ja jetzt zu einem
ende zu kommen durch die eu kommission
ist kenne alle wirtschaftlichen
argumente die da noch rolle spielen aber
sind hier geht noch tragbar angesichts
der lage in der ukraine muss man jetzt
vor einem moralischen hintergrund
einfach sagen so feierabend wir suchen
nach alternativen auf der stelle und wir
drehen im berühmten gashahn jetzt von
uns aus zu also bei öl und kohle haben
sie ja zu recht darauf hingewiesen da
sind wir dabei ein ausstiegs ziel ein
ausstiegsdatum festzulegen zusammen mit
den europäischen partnern und das kann
auch relativ rasch geschehen nach allem
was wir hören vom
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bei gas
komplizierter und da halten wir daran
fest wir können nicht aus einem
moralischen impetus heraus eine sanktion
verhängen die uns auch in große
schwierigkeiten bringen und die
dauerhaftigkeit der sanktionspolitik und
die nachhaltigkeit auch unsere
wirtschaftspolitik gefährdet denn der
ukraine ist ja nicht geholfen dadurch
dass wir uns selber schädigen sondern
dass wir weiteren sie finanziell und
militärisch unterstützen
und ich glaube nach dem massaker in
butter und wahrscheinlich auch ein
anderer stelle kommt es mehr denn je
darauf an mit waffen liefern konkret den
militärischen abwehr kampf der ukraine
zu unterstützen und genau das wollen wir
tun ein bisschen was kriegen wir noch
hin am 10 märz hat friedrich merz
gefordert auch nord stream 1 quasi
abzuschalten wenn man das so formulieren
kann ist das immer noch position der
union ja selbstverständlich wir sind für
mehr entschiedenheit und es ist
bedauerlicherweise so alles was wir an
russland zahlen in welcher währung auch
immer hilft ende putin diesen krieg
fortzusetzen und wir wollen nicht dass
putin gewinn sondern dass die ukraine
gewinnt und wenn das ernst gemeint ist
das jetzt wirklich die waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine effektiver und schneller
und werden dann wäre das sehr gut und
wichtig aber es muss auch geschehen das
was bisher da er seitens insbesondere
der verteidigungsministerin geleistet
worden ist das ist mehr chaos und
unstimmigkeit und deswegen ist die
bundesregierung hier gefordert jetzt
endlich effektiver zu werden und das
müsse an dieser stelle so stehen lassen
vielleicht widerspricht der
bundeskanzlerin ich schon gesehen habe
im plenarsaal auf dem monitor den ich
hier in dieser richtung ich habe der ist
schon da sie dürfen jetzt auch ganz fix
reingehen danke dass sie heute mittag
bei uns gewesen sind vielen dank herr
wadephul vielen dank herr schmid und mir
meine damen und herren schauen direkt
rein in den plenarsaal des bundestags
wenn ich richtig informiert bin wird es
vor der befragung des bundeskanzlers ein
beitrag des fdp-abgeordneten branden
eingeben da geht es um die
geschäftsordnung insbesondere um die
allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
hintergrund ist wahrscheinlich der am 10
märz lassen die erlassene
allgemeinverfügung zum thema masken
pflicht und zugangsregeln wir werden das
gleiche sehen sie haben den gong im
hintergrund gehört und die abgeordnete
neben sich und auch die
bundestagspräsidentin ist da da geb ich
doch mal rein
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bitte nehmen
sie platz begrüßen sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die berichte ausputzer erschüttern die
welt
nach dem abzug russischer truppen wurden
unbegreifliche
gräueltaten sichtbar
unsere gedanken sind bei den menschen in
borodjanka in marie pohl in kharkiv in
person und an so vielen anderen orten in
der ukraine
städte werden belagert evakuierung und
humanitäre hilfe blockiert die
versorgung mit lebensmitteln wasser und
strom wird systematisch gekappt es geht
offensichtlich um terror gegen das ganze
volk
der deutsche bundestag verurteilt diese
kriegsverbrechen aufs schärfste
auf antrag der koalitionsfraktionen
werden wir später in einer aktuellen
stunde zu den von russischen truppen
verübten massakern an ukrainischen
zivilisten in butter und den sich daraus
ergebenden konsequenzen debattieren
diese massaker müssen unabhängig
untersucht und die verantwortlichen
angeklagt werden hier ist auch die
internationale gemeinschaft gefragt
ohne
wahrheit kann es keine gerechtigkeit
geben
das gilt nicht nur in diesem krieg
menschenrechtsverletzungen müssen in
jedem fall dokumentiert und die opfer
gehört werden dabei spielen
menschenrechtsorganisationen eine
wichtige rolle und ich begrüße auf der
tribüne die historikerin irina
scherbakowa die die russische
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
mitbegründet hat mit weiteren
vertreterinnen und vertretern
vielen dank dass sie heute bei uns sind
die
bilder aus der ukraine wecken
erinnerungen an den krieg in bosnien
herzegowina der vor 30 jahren begann
mehr als 100.000 menschen kamen damals
ums leben auch darüber werden wir heute
nachmittag im plenum debattieren wie
jetzt in der ukraine wurden auch frauen
ziel brutaler gewalt bosnische frauen
brachten die kraft und den mut auf über
erlittene vergewaltigung zu sprechen sie
machten die wahrheit über diese
kriegsverbrechen bekannt der krieg
gipfelte in einem völkermord von
srebrenica bei dem 8000 bosnische
muslime vor allem jungen und männer
planvoll ermordet wurden alles deutet
darauf hin dass in diesen wochen in
europa
wieder unbeteiligte menschen zum ziel
von kriegsverbrechen werden wir müssen
alles
verantwortbare tun um die ukraine in
ihrem kampf um ihre existenz
noch stärker zu unterstützen
wir hier im bundestag wissen in der
ukraine geht es auch um europas frieden
und unsere sicherheit
[Applaus]
anmerkung der
bundestagspräsidentin unter anderem zu
ihrem treffen in wwe scherbakowa von
memorial der nichtregierungsorganisation
die seit dezember 21 in russland
verboten ist
müssen wir zunächst über die
tagesordnung der heutigen 27
sitzungen der morgigen
28 sitzung und der 29 sitzung am freitag
abstimmen zwischen den fraktionen
konnten zu diesen sitzungen keine
tagesordnung vereinbart werden die
fraktion der afg hat dem vorschlag der
anderen fraktionen widersprochen ich
habe daher den bundestag mit der
vorgeschlagenen tagesordnung einberufen
nach § 21 absatz 3 der geschäftsordnung
ist für die genehmigung der tagesordnung
ein plenar beschluss erforderlich
interfraktionelle es vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkte liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist für den beginn der beratung soll
soweit erforderlich abgewichen werden im
anschluss an die fragestunde findet
heute auf verlangen der fraktionen der
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp eine
aktuelle stunde statt das thema lautet
zu den von russischen truppen verübten
massakern an ukrainischen zivilisten in
butter und die den sich daraus
ergebenden konsequenzen
die tagesordnungspunkte 10 buchstabe b
und der tagesordnungspunkt 18 werden
abgesetzt den geänderten ablauf im
übrigen einschließlich der daraus
resultierenden änderungen bei den
debatten zeiten können sie der
zusatzpunkte liste entnehmen
damit kommen wir zur feststellung der
tagesordnung der 27 28 und 29 sitzung
mit den genannten änderungen und
ergänzungen
wer stimmt für diese tagesordnung
wer stimmt dagegen das ist die afg
fraktion die übrigen fraktionen waren
für die tagesordnung gibt es
enthaltungen das sehe ich nicht damit
ist die tagesordnung so beschlossen
bevor wir mit der befragung beginnen ist
mir mitgeteilt worden dass der kollege
brandner das wort zu einer bemerkung zur
geschäftsordnung wünscht er brandmal sie
haben das wort
[Applaus]
ja frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren zunächst mal vielen dank für das
wort zur geschäftsordnung
corona ist nicht vorbei was allerdings
vorbei ist sehr damen und herren ist die
zeit für maßlos übertriebene corona
maßnahmen die maßnahmen mit denen sie
von den altparteien zwei jahre lang
draußen die menschen im lande gegängelt
und schikaniert schikaniert haben diese
zeit ist vorbei wenn sie überhaupt je da
war diese zeit für corona maßnahmen dass
sie das erkannt haben da steckt dafür
haben sie im letzten
infektionsschutzgesetz dokumentiert dass
die menschen wieder in die freiheit
entlassen werden sollen wobei freiheit
eigentlich nur das ist was bis vor zwei
jahren selbstverständlichkeiten waren
nämlich dass man sich wann man möchte
dahin begeben kann wo man hin man möchte
das sind also selbstverständlichkeiten
die sie die menschen zurückgegeben haben
aber immerhin den ländern haben sie ein
instrument an die hand gegeben notstand
oder katastrophengebiete in deutschland
auszurufen und nach wie vor unter ein
ganz schlimmes corona regime zu stellen
von diesen notstandsgebieten in
deutschland gibt es noch drei stück alle
von der spd nominiert notstandsgebiet in
mecklenburg vorpommern notstands
katastrophengebiet in hamburg und
offenbar notstands und
katastrophengebiet dieser deutsche
bundestag und deshalb werde ich mich
jetzt zu wort
deshalb wähle ich mich hier zu wort und
problematisieren die nach wie vor
bestehende testpflicht und masken
pflicht die außerhalb des deutschen
bundestages schon drei meter weiter in
berlin gar keine rolle mehr spielt die
präsidentin hat die allgemeinverfügung
für diese woche noch verlängert ich
hoffe das ändert sich dann im laufe der
nächsten woche gleichwohl wollen wir von
der alternative für deutschland nichts
unversucht lassen um dieses corona
regime je im deutschen bundestag auch zu
beenden deshalb meine bitte an die
präsidentin um das könnten sie jetzt
hier tun frau waas von ihrem präsidenten
stuhl aus heben sie die
allgemeinverfügung leben sie die unter
dem hausrecht verbreitete
allgemeinverfügung mit sofortiger
wirkung auf damit wir uns hier wieder
alle ins gesicht schauen können und eine
debatte führen können oder debatten
führen können so wie wir es seit jahren
gewohnt sind
heben sie bitte dann wenn sie dich
aufheben dann beantrage ich namens die
fdp-fraktion hier mit einem beschluss
des plenums herbeizuführen indem
abgestimmt wird über die verlängerte
haus verfügung die allgemeinverfügung
die sie herausgegeben haben mit dem ziel
diese hier durch das plenum aufheben zu
lassen und um das ganze dann noch
perfekt zu machen weiß ich sie darauf
hin dass wir am morgigen tage ohne
debatte leider aber eine abstimmung
haben zu einem afg antrag der da lautet
tag der freiheit auch im deutschen
bundestag das sollten wir uns gönnen
können wir uns das was wir den menschen
draußen können heben wir die
übergangsvorschrift des § 126 g oder
ausnahme vorschriften statuiert um den
deutschen bundestag arbeitsfähig zu
halten auf diese ausnahme vorschriften
braucht es nicht mehr die
allgemeinverfügung braucht es nicht mehr
deshalb meine bitte geben sie die auf
oder ansonsten liebes plenum lassen sie
uns gemeinsam diese allgemeinverfügung
aufheben vielen dank
stefan rentner außerhalb der fraktion
der in berlin offenbar keine
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel nutzen
müsste er das da die masken pflicht
weiterhin gilt
herr kollege brandner
wie sie wissen
stehen nach der verfassung mir als
präsidentin das hausrecht zu
und insofern entscheide ich ob einem das
gefällt oder nicht über das hausrecht
und mit welchen maßnahmen wir
als bei einrichtung die korona
bedingungen
beide messen er hat aber einen antrag
gestellt
und damit muss ich ihnen leider sagen
den habe ich wohl vernommen den kann ich
aber nicht abstimmen lassen weil er
unzulässig ist weil wir über das
hausrecht der präsidentin hier im plenum
nicht abstimmen
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es ein gremium wo
wir genau diese dinge besprechen und das
werden wir auch morgen am donnerstag ton
und ich lade sie herzlich ein morgen in
der ältestenratssitzung wo das thema
hingehört über die weiteren maßnahmen
zur pandemie im deutschen bundestag und
in ausschüssen mit mir zu diskutieren
bitte
damit kommen wir jetzt zur tagesordnung
die befragung der bundesregierung
die bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
zur verfügung steht
herr bundeskanzler sie haben das wort
für ihre einleitenden ausführungen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
entsetzlichen bilder aus sotschi haben
uns alle tief in chile erschüttert
russische soldaten haben dort vor ihrem
rückzug ein massaker an ukrainischen
zivilisten verübt darunter kinder frauen
und alte menschen die
von russland verbreitete zynische
behauptung es handle sich bei diesem
thema um eine inszenierung fällt auf
diejenigen zurück die diese lügen
verbreiten die ermordung von zivilisten
ist ein kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen die täter und ihre
auftraggeber müssen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden darum unterstützen wir
alle internationalen bemühung solche
greueltaten nun minutiös zu
dokumentieren und schonungslos
aufzuklären in butter und auch darüber
hinaus
das sollten wir ja nicht vergessen wir
müssen ja damit rechnen dass wir noch
weitere solche bilder sehen werden auch
die europäische union hat der ukraine
alle hilfe in dieser angelegenheit
zugesagt
meine damen und herren unterdessen geht
das töten des russischen militärs weiter
unvermindert
und deshalb fordere ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal den russischen präsidenten
auf
beenden sie diesen zerstörerischen und
selbstzerstörerischen krieg sofort
ziehen sie ihre truppen aus der ukraine
ab
und bis das geschieht setzen wir
weiterhin alles daran die ukraine
bestmöglich zu unterstützen
immer abgestimmt mit unseren freunden
und verbündeten
dazu gehört auch
dass wir aus den aktuellen beständen der
bundeswehr waffen liefern können
alles das was sinnvoll ist und schnell
wirkt das wird geliefert
ich weiß dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht alles unternimmt was
angesichts der beschlusslage unserer
alliierten und mit blick auf die
fähigkeiten der bundeswehr machbar ist
diese regierung hat
anders als ihre vorgängerin beschlossen
waffen zu liefern und seither tun wir
das
die klare prämisse bleibt
dabei aber auch klar mit allen
entscheidungen die wir treffen
werden wir sicherstellen dass die
nato-partner keine kriegspartei werden
wir haben neben der militärischen
unterstützung über die ich gesprochen
habe und die wir täglich leisten und
auch weiter leisten werden auch
humanitäre unterstützung zur verfügung
gestellt für die ukraine und die
nachbarländer
noch mal neu fast eine halbe milliarde
euro zusätzlich zu den zwei milliarden
die wir den letzten jahren bereits zur
verfügung gestellt haben und diese
zivile hilfe werden wir fortsetzen
erst gestern hat die bundes
außenministerin hier in berlin zu einer
unterstützungs konferenz für moldau
gebieten
ist eines der
ärmsten länder europas
es hat pro kopf mehr geflüchtete
aufgenommen als alle anderen länder und
es braucht und verdient unsere
unterstützung
hunderttausende kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine sind in den letzten wochen
nach deutschland gekommen und es werden
mehr werden
sie sind hier willkommen das will ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
und wir werden gemeinsam mit den ländern
in deutschland morgen wichtige
entscheidungen treffen was all die
fragen betrifft die damit zusammenhängen
registrierung unterbringung und
natürlich auch die gemeinsame
finanzierung
gesamtstaatliche aufgaben auch dies als
eine bemerkung von mir ich wünsche mir
dass wir nicht eine ewig lange
diskussion über die finanziellen fragen
zwischen den verschiedenen ebenen
unseres landes haben sondern dass wir
uns schnell und zügig einigen zwischen
dem bund den ländern dass wir die
interessen der kommunen und landkreise
hier
berücksichtigen dass wir eine gute
einigung und verständigung haben damit
wir uns der eigentlichen aufgabe
zuwenden können wir helfen wir den
flüchtlingen die hier schutz gesucht
haben
und für uns alle sollte ein ansporn sein
die solidarität die die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes jeden tag zeigen
denn es gibt sehr viel solidarität sehr
viel unterstützung überall in
deutschland und ich bin sehr dankbar
dafür diese hilfe ist wichtig und sie
tut gut
und schließlich werden wir den druck auf
russland weiter erhöhen zum beispiel mit
den sanktionen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben die sind lange
vorbereitet lange bevor der krieg
ausgebrochen worden so brauchen ist
haben wir darüber gesprochen
wir haben sie
vereinbart mit der eu-kommission und wir
sind dabei die aktuellen sanktion noch
einmal zu verschärfen das fünfte paket
ist in der finalen debatte und es wird
noch einmal präzise dazu beitragen dass
russland die folgen dieses krieges spürt
auch um zu erreichen dass es den krieg
beendet
es muss unser ziel bleiben dass russland
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt das ist dass
es hinter den aktivitäten steht die wir
unternehmen wenn es nun um waffen die
führung geht wenn es um finanzielle und
humanitäre unterstützung geht wenn es um
die aufnahme der flüchtlinge geht oder
um die sanktions pakete die wir global
und wird weltweit vereinbaren und
natürlich gehört dazu auch dass wir die
abhängigkeiten reduzieren denn dem wir
uns heute befinden
und dazu gehört natürlich auch die
reduktion der abhängigkeit vom import
russischer energie
wir wissen alle diese abhängigkeiten
sind über jahrzehnte gewachsen und sie
lassen sich nicht von einem tag auf den
anderen beenden
deshalb ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass
wir uns in europa gemeinsam auf den weg
gemacht haben genau das zu schaffen und
gemeinsam einen kurs abgesteckt haben
mit dem wir das auch tatsächlich tun
jetzt während dieses krieges aber die
weichen sind gestellt und sie werden
auch nach dem krieg weiter einen den
kurs vorgeben bin wird zu gehen haben
und gleichzeitig geht es nicht nur darum
neue import dinieren möglich zu machen
und neue importkapazitäten und neue
vertragspartner zu finden sondern
langfristig auch die unabhängigkeit von
fossilen ressourcen zu organisieren die
dann tatsächlich eine sichere
perspektive für europa schafft und
gleichzeitig hilft den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
wir werden jetzt mit großer
geschwindigkeit lg kapazitäten an der
norddeutschen küste aufbauen wir werden
die netze ausbauen die dazu erforderlich
sind wir werden die im pop strukturen
für kohle öl und gas so organisieren
dass wir auf dauer nicht mehr abhängig
sind von den russischen importen das
werden wir mit nie gekannter
geschwindigkeit tun und heute hat das
kabinett dazu einen ganz wichtigen
beitrag geleistet mit einer entscheidung
die ohnehin zu den plänen dieser
regierung zählte und diese sorgfältig
vorbereitet haben aber die jetzt
unbedingt und noch viel mehr notwendig
ist mit dem oster paket zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien in deutschland zur
stärkung der energienetze zeigen wir was
wir vorhaben jetzt erst recht werden wir
uns unabhängig machen von der nutzung
fossiler ressourcen das ist unsere
aufgabe
vielen dank bevor wir mit der befragen
beginn ein paar vorbemerkung von mir wir
haben jetzt über die fraktionen bereits
sehr viele wortmeldungen
gemeldet bekommen und in der kanzler
oder kanzlerin befragung ist es
üblicherweise so dass wir so verfahren
dass wir die fragesteller aufrufen dass
eine nachfrage gestellt werden kann ich
aber üblicherweise dann nicht mehr
weitere fragen über andere fraktionen
zum thema zu lassen sondern wir dann in
die nächst in den nächsten frage block
gehen nur dass das einmal noch mal
erklärt wird weil wir das bei anderen
befragung ja durchaus anders machen in
dem dann auch das fragerecht auf andere
fraktion übergeht zum gleichen thema
das einleitend noch mal damit dass für
alle fraktionen klar ist und ich rufe
zuerst zur befragung auf den kollegen dr
johann wadephul für die cdu/csu-fraktion
kanzler zum thema waffenlieferungen hat
sich der vorsitzende der grünen in
deutschland omid nouripour den
vergangenen tagen geäußert und er hat
dazu gesagt dass die leistung der
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht sehr unzureichend sei weil
keine hinreichende
synchronisation zwischen den wünschen
der ukraine und den möglichkeiten
deutschlands waffen zu liefern
stattfindet teilen sie diese auffassung
und wenn ja was gedenken sie zu tun um
die missstände abzustellen sie haben
vorsitzenden der grünen völlig
missverstanden ich hatte gestern das
privileg mit ihm länger ein gespräch zu
führen oder hat mir das gegenteil gesagt
gerade für sie können in afrika ich
würde dann die nachfrage darzustellen
wie hat er ihnen denn sein zusatz
erklärt dass wir neben gleichen
interview darauf hingewiesen hat dass
größere mengen schützenpanzer marder
herr umständen die in die ukraine
verbracht werden könnten und wo dies
nicht geschehe und ich verbinde das mit
dem hinweis dass es mehrere
rüstungsunternehmen in deutschland gibt
die anfragen von der ukraine haben dass
waffen geliefert werden könnten die
ukraine zahlungsbereit ist es aber an
genehmigungen seitens ihrer regierung
fehlt was sagen sie dazu ich möchte
gerne noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
es ein bruch mit langen tradition ist
dass diese regierung anders als alle
ihre vorgängerinnen entschieden hat
überhaupt waffen in die ukraine und in
ein krisengebiet zu liefern das ist eine
richtige entscheidung die wir abgewogen
aber auch schnell getroffen haben es ist
interessant zu beobachten dass viele
dede entscheidungen der vergangenheit
bisher immer unterstützt hatten jetzt
plötzlich alle möglichen vorschläge
haben wie es jetzt weitergehen soll aber
der eigentliche weg die eigentliche
entscheidung war die dass wir es
überhaupt tun und jetzt nutzen wir
unsere möglichkeiten das machen wir
einerseits abgestimmt mit unseren
freundinnen und freunden in der nato und
der europäischen union weil es darum
geht dass alle in gleiche richtung gehen
und nicht unterschiedlicher aktivitäten
unternehmen zweiter treffen wir diese
entscheidung nach sorgfältiger
vorbereitung in den dazu notwendigen
gremien wo wir auch dafür sorgen dass
die sicherheit der bundesrepublik
deutschland dabei sorgfältig beachtet
wird und im übrigen ist es so dass wir
dabei alles was richtig und sinnvoll ist
auf den weg bringen
präsident der meidet
ja das ist aber ich erwarte dann auch
eine antwort auf meine frage und ich
habe darauf hingewiesen dass
sie am 3 wir haben meine antwort auf
diese frage bekommen allerdings müssen
sie sich noch mit dem thema beschäftigen
warum sie die politik der
bundesregierung die sie jetzt
unterstützen nicht richtig gefunden
haben früher zu anderen zeiten war sie
früher anlage war gerade vor bitte ich
weiß aber sie haben eine nachfrage und
sie können ja nachher noch einmal über
die nächsten fragesteller nachhaken die
nächste kolleginnen die die frage stellt
ist vieles polat von bündnis 90 die
grünen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz ich
möchte romani rose zitieren romani rose
ist vorsitzender des zentralrats
deutscher sinti und roma und er warnte
erst kürzlich vor der ungleichbehandlung
von geflüchteten
romney und bezeichnete die bisher
bekannten einzelfälle von
diskriminierung als besorgniserregend er
drückt er drückte seine erwartung aus
dass jetzt zitiere ich dass unser staat
ukrainischen roma die als
kriegsflüchtlinge nach deutschland
kommen den gleichen schutz gewährt
bekommen wie alle anderen ukrainischen
staatsbürger innen aus wird sich unsere
bundesregierung genauso
gegenüber den ukrainischen roma
bekümmern wie es für die anderen
ukrainischen geflüchtete aus der ukraine
vorgesehen ist
schönen dank für ihre frage in der tat
geht es darum dass wir hier allen
gleichermaßen gerecht werden das haben
wir mit der entscheidung da die
europaweit getroffen worden ist und die
in deutschland eben auch besondere
großzügige weise auch ausgelegt worden
ist ja haben möglich gemacht dass
diejenigen hier einreisen können die
ukrainische staatsbürger sind und das
gilt für die von ihnen
genannten genauso wie für alle anderen
und darüber hinaus möglich gemacht dass
auch diejenigen die aufrechte zum
beispiel in der ukraine haben ebenfalls
hier einreisen können unabhängig von
ihrer staatsbürgerschaft um dieses
basiere ihre frage nicht ging aber das
finde ich muss bei dieser gelegenheit
gesagt werden und deshalb kann ich ihnen
versichern die bundesregierung wird
alles dafür tun dass niemand
diskriminiert wird und dass alle gleich
behandelt werden
coppola sie können eine nachfrage
stellen wenn sie möchten vielen dank
frau präsidentin
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz
vielen dank für diese für diesen hit für
diese hinweise ich werde dann noch mal
auf sie zukommen die zweite frage ist
unter den roh unter der roma minderheit
sind auch einige holocaust-überlebende
die bereits deutschland erreicht haben
wird es ähnlich wie bei den jüdischen
holocaust-überlebenden eine gemeinsame
evakuierungsaktion auch von
holocaust-überlebenden der
roma-minderheit
geben zusammen mit anderen
organisationen wie zum beispiel des
zentralrats
wir haben uns überhaupt verpflichtet
dass wir neben denjenigen die schutz
finden weil sie hierher kommen und
darüber haben sie gerade berichtet
darüber hinaus auch evakuierung
vornehmen die ganz ganz schwierig sind
und sehr sorgfältig vorbereitet werden
es handelt sich bei den
holocaust-überlebenden um hochbetagte
bürgern und bürger der ukraine die den
schrecklichen holocaust überlebt haben
und deshalb natürlich unseren besonderen
schutz verdienen und wir sind eng
abgestimmt mit den europäischen
verbündeten im hinblick auf das was
getan werden kann um das zu organisieren
das sind ja auch ganz komplizierte
transporte wie man sich angesichts des
alters und oft auch der
pflegebedürftigkeit sehr gut vorstellen
kann
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
leif erik holm von der fdp fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler die bürger und unternehmen
dieses landes warten dringend auf
entlastung von den explodierten
energiepreisen das entlastungspaket hat
ihre regierung versprochen und es ist
wirklich dringend notwendig ein
musterhaushalt erwartet in diesem jahr
etwa 3200 euro an mehrausgaben für
energie für strom gas wasser kraftstoffe
und das alles muss dringend abgefedert
werden wir sehen doch die ergebnisse
bisher schon wir sehen pendler die nicht
mehr zur arbeit fahren matthias
schmeißen ihren job hin weil es sich
einfach nicht mehr lohnt und das kann so
doch nicht weitergehen deswegen braucht
es eine entlastung und zwar dringend in
anderen ländern um uns herum passiert
das in polen belgien in frankreich
italien da sind die linderung schon
längst in kraft wo bleibt das
entlastungspaket ihrer regierung warum
schafft es deutschland unter einem
kanzler scholz nicht für schnelle
entlastung der bürger und unternehmen zu
sorgen
schönen dank für die frage sie
ermöglicht mir noch einmal das lob das
sie darin untergebracht haben hier zu
verstärken tatsächlich ist es so dass
diese regierung zwei entlastungspaket
bereits auf den weg gebracht haben mit
einem umfang von zusammen etwa 30
milliarden euro ich glaube dass das in
der dimension an der spitze dessen nicht
was in europa überhaupt organisiert
worden ist und wir haben unsere
entsprechenden möglichkeiten genutzt wir
haben bei dieser gelegenheit all die
verschiedenen
schwierigen lagen der bürgern und bürger
berücksichtigt wir haben etwas getan für
diejenigen die auf grundsicherung
angewiesen sind wir haben für
geringverdiener etwas getan mit dem
höheren heizkostenzuschuss wir tun etwas
für pendlerinnen und pendler mit einer
erhöhten entsprechenden
entfernungspauschale
wir machen etwas blatt für die
entlastung bei den benzinkosten wir
haben etwas gemacht für diejenigen die
auf den öffentlichen nahverkehr
angewiesen sind wir haben steuerliche
erleichterung auf den weg gebracht was
den arbeitnehmer freibetrag den
grundfreibetrag betrifft wir haben etwas
auf den weg gebracht für die familien
eine bonuszahlung und wir machen etwas
als sonderzahlung für die armen kinder
in dieser republik also da kommt eine
ganze menge zusammen danke dass sie es
gelobt haben der eine teil ist schon auf
dem gesetzgebungs fahrt der andere folgt
jetzt schnell hinterher und wenn sie
mithelfen kriegen wir auch die
gesetzgebung mit zweiter dritter lesung
und zustimmung des bundesrates mit
eiltempo durch bundestag und bundesrat
hier haben sie haben das recht seine
nachfragen mit verlaub herr
bundeskanzler aus ihren worten spricht
der blanke hohn für diejenigen die wenig
geld verdienen und 3300 euro
möglicherweise an mehrkosten in diesem
jahr haben und die davon eben noch nicht
in weiten teilen entlastet sind ich habe
die pendler angesprochen ich habe noch
nicht angesprochen die fuhrunternehmer
die jetzt schon vor lauter not auf die
straße gehen mit ihren großen lastern
dort straßenblockaden errichten bei mir
in der heimat in mecklenburg vorpommern
beispielsweise und das sehen wir doch
dass es brennt an allen ecken und sie
sagen hier heute die entlastung kommt
bald auch beim sprit was ist denn das
ihre zur abstimmung dann fertig wann
geht das gesetzgebungsverfahren los wir
wollen antworten die bürger wollen
antworten von ihnen wann kommt die
entlastung auf scholz' also
dass sich die mühe macht könnten sie die
antwort aus ihren eigenen unterlagen
entnehmen dass eine gesetzgebung paket
ist bereits auf dem weg und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen
lasse ich mir schon öfter gedanken
gemacht habe über ihr
demokratieverständnis aber gesetze
werden in diesem land nicht von der
regierung sondern vom deutschen
bundestag gemacht und das
dann muss ich mal die durchkommen
das
fragerecht geht jetzt an die kollegin
annika merten von der fdp fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin an die
kometen alles gut herr bundeskanzler der
ukrainische präsident seelands kiel hat
im zuge der verhandlungen mit russland
über ein friedensabkommen im
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
die neutralität der ukraine gegenzug für
sicherheitsgarantien der internationalen
gemeinschaft angeboten die
bundesregierung hat hierzu ihre
grundsätzliche bereitschaft signalisiert
sich an solchen sicherheitsgarantien für
die ukraine zu beteiligen
dies unterstützen wir ausdrücklich und
begleiten wir auch sehr gerne daher und
auch vor dem hintergrund dass bereits
auf dem eu-gipfel von versailles
erfolgten einstimmigen bekenntnis der eu
mitgliedstaaten zur unterstützung der
ukraine
auf ihrem weg in die eu die frage wie
könnten solche sicherheitsgarantien
konkret aussehen vielen dank
in der tat ist es so dass gegenwärtig
verhandlung stattfinden der die frage
der neutralität eine rolle spielt was
das muss an dieser stelle gesagt werden
aus der sicht der ukraine ein großes
zugeständnis ist gegenüber dem aggressor
und bei allem was gegenwärtig in den
verhandlung stattfindet ist mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen es darf nicht auf einen
diktate frieden hinauslaufen das muss
immer klar sein und wenn wir reden mit
der russischen seite wenn ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten rede dann mache
ich auch sehr klar es sind die ukraine
ukraine die über das was sie zu
vereinbaren bereits sind verhandeln
niemand sonst
in diesem zusammenhang ist die frage der
sicherheitsgarantien angesprochen worden
die noch nicht ausbuchstabiert sind
selbstverständlich reden wir darüber
aber dass auch in der notwendige
vertraulichkeit mit der ukraine und tun
das auch mit den anderen die
angesprochen sind ob sie dort eine rolle
spielen könnten es
entspringt eigentlich der natur der
sache dass sich das nicht weiter
konkretisieren lässt weil erst mal ja
die fragen die da garantiert werden
müssen geregelt werden müssen und
deshalb bitte ich um nachsicht dass ich
so allgemein bleibe wie unsere erklärung
bisher zu diesem thema nur sein kann
sie können einen anfang stellen ich
bedanke mich für die worte und hat sich
da auf die nachfrage
danke damit geht das rederecht an die
kollegin susanne ferschl von der
fraktion die linke
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler
ich hoffe sie haben sich mittlerweile zu
den fakten kundig gemacht mini jobs
verdrängen reguläre beschäftigung das
ist nicht bestandteil linker flugblätter
sondern es belegen wissenschaftliche
studien allen voran die des ib und sie
führt insbesondere bei frauen dazu dass
dienen darf teilzeit falle feststecken
beides schließen sie jetzt letztendlich
in einem koalitionsvertrag aus
versprechen also da dass es nicht zur
verdrängung kommt das ist nicht zu einer
teilzeit falle kommt und ich fragte sie
wie wollen sie dieses versprechen
realisieren wenn sie die mini jobs aber
gleichzeitig ausweiten
das was in deutschland stattfindet ist
etwas über das ich sehr froh bin wir
haben endlich in aussicht eine
gesetzgebung über einen höheren
mindestlohn von 12 euro der in diesem
jahr noch kommen wird der wird dazu
führen dass viele viele millionen
arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer mehr geld
verdienen als sie gegenwärtig verdienen
in diesem zusammenhang haben wir ein
festes verhältnis für die höhe des der
minijobs im verhältnis zu dem
entwicklung des mindestlohns geschrieben
das ist ein stück rationalität für die
zukunft aber wir haben genau wegen der
von ihnen gestellten frage uns auch
gedanken gemacht wie kann man den
übergang nur bis gut organisieren damit
niemand der jetzt wegen des höheren
mindestlohns mehr geld verdient
gewissermaßen sich irgendwie bewegt
fühlt darauf zu verzichten jetzt
sozialversichert beschäftigt zu sein und
deshalb ist das ein teil des
gesetzgebungsvorhabens dass wir auf den
weg gebracht haben hier die gleitzone
noch freundlicher auszugestalten mit der
klaren perspektive jeder höhere lohn
soll auch zu einem höheren
nettoeinkommen führen das ist die
zielsetzung
prof sie können dann nachfrage danke
frau präsidentin der bundeskanzler
mindestlohn ist das entsprechende
stichwort die mini jobs bei einer
gleichzeitig fehlenden
arbeitszeiterfassung sind das
haupteinfallstor beim mindestlohn betrug
und sie warten jetzt auf der einen seite
die minijob regelung ausführen aber
nicht die manipulationssichere
arbeitszeiterfassung 1 das heißt wir
wollen sie sicherstellen dass nicht
weiterhin millionen beschäftigte um
ihren ihnen zustehenden mindestlohn
betrogen werden und wie wollen sie dafür
sorgen dass die erhöhung auch
entsprechend beiden kolleginnen und
kollegen ankommt auch die arbeitszeit
von minijobbern muss dokumentiert werden
da gibt es keinen unterschied zu
denjenigen die normale
arbeitsverhältnisse haben das soll meine
teile ich ihre prämisse nicht und
selbstverständlich gehört auch zum
arbeitsleben wie im öffentlichen leben
ansonsten auch dass es notwendig ist
dass recht und ordnung auch durchgesetzt
werden in diesem fall recht und ordnung
auf dem arbeitsmarkt und die dazu
notwendige behörde ist den letzten
jahren beständig ausgebaut worden und
wird auch weiter ausgebaut werden sage
ich im hinblick auf den das
vorantreibenden hinter mir sitzen den
bundesminister der finanzen wir werden
den zoll und die finanzkontrolle
schwarzarbeit so ausbauen dass sie sich
darauf verlassen können wir gegen algen
betrugsversuchen hinterher
nächste fragestellerin ist die kollegin
dagmar andres und der spd fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler unbestritten
ist der krieg in der ukraine eine
ungeahnte herausforderungen
beispielslose art und damit auch eine
bewährungsprobe für den zusammenhalt
innerhalb europas egal ob jetzt aufgrund
der wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
auf grund der flucht bewegungen oder
auch aufgrund der akuten militärischen
bedrohung durch russland vor diesem
hintergrund möchte ich sie fragen in
welchen bereichen ist europa jetzt
besonders gefordert und in welchen
bereichen eröffnen sich durch diese
krise womöglich auch neue spielräume
neue chancen um den europäischen
zusammenhalt weiter voranzubringen und
können sie bitte konkretisieren welche
impulse die bundesregierung hier in den
nächsten wochen und monaten setzen wird
schönen dank
angesichts der ukraine krise kann man
sagen hat sich der russische präsident
ja mehrfach verrechnet er hat sich
verrechnet in hinblick auf den
widerstand der ukraine ukraine dieses
die russische invasion ja
zurückgeschlagen haben im verhältnis zu
dem was da ursprünglich intendiert war
wie das weitergeht das können wir alle
hier nicht vorhersagen aber das was dort
an widerstand geleistet worden es war
sehr groß aber er hat sich auch
verrechnet in hinblick auf die einigkeit
von uns allen auch die einigkeit der
europäischen union die sich an den
global vereinbarten sanktions paketen
mit großer wärme beteiligt hat sie mit
vorangetrieben hat und diese einigkeit
müssen wir jetzt nutzen für große
fortschritte in europa damit dass ein
momentum ergibt das weit darüber hinaus
geht aus meiner sicht ist es wichtig
dass wir jetzt
politisch mit den herausforderungen
umgehen die sich auch durch die
russische aggression und die
wirtschaftlichen folgen auch der
sanktions entscheidungen ergeben und das
bedeutet wir müssen zuallererst dafür
sorgen dass europa was die
energieversorgung betrifft auf eigenen
füßen steht und sich unabhängig macht
von fossilen ressourcen insbesondere den
notwendigkeit kohle öl und gas zu
importieren genau das tun wir mit den
paketen die in europa besprochen werden
und das ist der eine große notwendige
bausteine für fortschritt und einigkeit
in europa
sie können an den nachfragen stehen sie
verzichten dann
geht das fragerecht über an in den
nächsten kollegen das ist florian hahn
von der cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
sie haben vorhin ausgeführt dass
vorgängerregierungen noch nie waffen in
krisengebiete
geliefert hätten möchte an der stelle
daran erinnern dass die schwarz rote
bundesregierung
2014 waffen in das krisengebiet irak
konkret an die peschmerga kurden
geliefert hat im übrigen gottseidank und
mit großem erfolg die frage ist also was
es mit ihrer aussage von freund zu
halten richtig ist auch dass die ukraine
schon länger
waffenlieferungen gerne hätte aus
deutschland und auch ihre regierung erst
sozusagen mit dem eintritt des krieges
sich um entschieden hat und diesen
waffenlieferungen diese
waffenlieferungen genehmigt hat ist das
richtige
wir sind die regierung die diese
entscheidung getroffen haben und die
reden entscheidung das richtig
also die vorgängerregierung hat das auch
entwickeln nach plan herr bundeskanzler
ich möchte sie außerdem fragen es gibt
eine große diskrepanz zwischen dem was
wir
öffentlich wahrnehmen was die
bundesregierung auf der einen seite
selber postuliert im sinne von wir
liefern so viel wie geht und dem was auf
der anderen seite auf der liste in der
geheimschutzstelle zu sehen ist oder was
auch tatsächlich in der öffentlichkeit
zu lesen ist oder auch was die ukraine
tatsächlich
sozusagen als feedback auf diese
lieferungen gibt meine frage ist
wie kann es sein dass wir über so viel
wochen praktisch keine veränderungen
haben bei der ausfuhr von waffen mit
blick auf die entsprechende liste in der
geheimschutzstelle und wie passt das
zusammen mit den äußerungen der
bundesregierung und passt es damit
zusammen dass sich die
bundesverteidigungsministerium damit
rühmt das deutschland der zweitgrößte
unterstützer beim thema
waffenlieferungen ist nach den usa
obwohl bekanntermaßen andere länder
deutlich mehr geliefert haben
schönen dank für ihre frage erst mal ist
es so dass wir in der tat viel liefern
wir haben am anfang das gemacht aus den
beständen die wir von in der bundeswehr
haben und die verfügbar sind und die
sich um waffen drehen die auch sinnvoll
sind und die auch einen ganz erheblichen
beitrag geleistet haben zu dem
militärischen aktivitäten der
ukrainischen armee spreche hier von den
panzerabwehrwaffen zum beispiel den
flugabwehrwaffen viel munition und
vielen was dazu gehört und wir sind
dabei jetzt gewissermaßen die bundeswehr
um deren stärkung wir uns ansonsten ja
auch noch gedanken machen damit sie in
zukunft viele bestände hat die viel
größer sind als heute dass nebenbei
welche möglichkeiten existieren für
industrielle lieferung darüber haben wir
sehr sorgfältig all die verschiedenen
angebote der industrie betrachtet und
bewertet und unsere vorstellung dazu
entwickelt und sind jetzt im engen
austausch mit der ukraine was dort
möglich ist sie wissen dass wir im
übrigen alles dafür getan haben dass
auch die finanziellen
handlungsmöglichkeiten der ukraine dazu
groß sind die eu hat mittlerweile eine
milliarde euro bereitgestellt für die
beschaffung von waffen und das ist auch
richtig
nächste frage stellen ist die kollegin
lisa bader aus fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler
diese krieg in europa hat uns ja auch
vor augen geführt wie energiepolitik und
sicherheitspolitik verzahnt sind sie
hatten darauf hingewiesen und das uns
unsere fossile abhängigkeit natürlich
auch verwundbar macht und ich sag mal
die co2 emissionen die sind das
spiegelbild diese abhängigkeit der
weltklimarat hat diese woche noch einmal
gesagt dass die unvermindert steigen
weltweit von daher bin ich ist sehr
begrüßenswert dass sie heute sagen jetzt
erst recht wir müssen mehr tun im kampf
gegen den menschengemachten klimawandel
und von daher wäre meine frage
vielleicht können sie noch einmal
konkret sagen in welchen bereichen in
der energiepolitik sowohl national als
auch auf eu ebene müssen aus ihrer sicht
die ambition nochmal angeschärft werden
damit wir letztendlich unabhängiger und
damit auch unverwundbare werden
es gibt wie ich eingangs gesagt habe
zwei
unterschiedliche fragestellungen zu
beantworten was machen wir schnell und
unmittelbar um die abhängigkeit von den
russischen importen zu reduzieren da
geht es auch um investitionen für zb
flüssiggas terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten und ähnliche
entscheidungen die etwas mit dem import
fossiler ressourcen zu tun haben bei dem
flüssiggas terminals ist das gute das
wir sie sowieso brauchen nämlich für den
später geplanten import auch von
wasserstoff der zu einer klimaneutralen
industriellen zukunft um die mitte des
jahrhunderts für europa spätestens 2 45
in deutschland dazu gehört und deshalb
ist es für uns ganz ganz wichtig dass
wir genau in diesem bereich die
notwendigen fortschritte jetzt zustande
bringt unser stromnetz ausbauen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir ein ordentliches
wasserstoff netz bekommen dafür sorge zu
tragen dass wir produktionskapazitäten
bekommen bei windkraft auf hoher see
land für solarenergie für die
möglichkeiten den damit verbunden sind
das machen wir auch in dem wir die
möglichkeit mehr auf strom zu setzen
verbessern indem man die kostenbelastung
die mit der eeg umlage für die
stromnetze rinnen und nutzer heute
verbunden sind abgeschafft wird aber das
machen wir eben auch mit einem massiven
boom bei den investitionen das ist der
weg den deutschland geht wo wir heute
einen wichtigen schritt für gegangen
sind aber es ist der weg der für ganz
europa wichtig ist
sie können eine nachfrage stimmt ja
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler
insbesondere auch für die aussicht dass
wir unsere gas partnerschaft natürlich
auch in grüne erneuerbare und
wasserstoff partnerschaften umwandeln
wollen in der zukunft jenseits dessen
was der bund tun muss ist natürlich eine
riesige herausforderung und ich denke
sie sehen es auch so dass wir die
ländern unserer seite brauchen haben sie
den eindruck dass manche bundesländer
vielleicht auch mit wenigen maßnahmen
noch mehr tun können um diese ambitionen
zu erhöhen zb waren windkraftausbau und
uns da auch zu unterstützen wenn der
windkraftausbau überall in deutschland
voran gehen muss muss er überall in
deutschland vorangehen um das ist also
in allen 16 ländern davon
das fragerecht geht jetzt an den
kollegen marc bernhard aus der fdp
fraktion
danke frau präsidentin
bundeskanzler deutschland importiert
derzeit rund 55 prozent seines erdgases
und die hälfte der steinkohle aus
russland und es hat gestern die
eu-kommission ja den importverbot für
russische kohle vorgeschlagen und
testens auch möglich und sie haben ja
selber auch gesagt dass wir da dringend
wegkommen muss müssen aber wir können
sofort machen denn ein einziges
kernkraftwerk liefert so viel energie
wie beispielsweise fünf prozent des
russischen gases oder 16 prozent der
russischen kola wenn wir also die drei
im dezember abgeschalteten
kernkraftwerke reaktivieren würden
können sie zusammen mit den drei noch
aktiven fast den gesamten russischen
kohle import ersetzen oder eben 30
prozent des russischen gases und jetzt
meine frage jetzt haben sie eine
zeitenwende eine lange angekündigt herr
bundeskanzler wasser die regierung
unternommen um die laufzeitverlängerung
und wieder inbetriebnahme der
kernkraftwerke in deutschland zeitnah zu
erreichen um eben für bezahlbare energie
und für unabhängigkeit von russischen
energielieferungen zu sorgen also
zunächst mal wenn die welt so einfach
wäre
wie sie sich in ihrer frage malen dann
hätten wir dann hätten wir ein sehr
gutes leben aber tatsächlich ist es so
dass zum beispiel ein großer teil der
fossilen importe die wir haben für
industrielle prozesse benötigt wird 80
prozent der energie in deutschland
verbraucht wird wird im wesentlichen
bereich der industrie verbraucht und
deshalb dürfen wir uns nicht ein
falsches bild machen das gilt übrigens
auch für die regionale verteilung und
für die frage wo es um stromproduktion
geht es um wärmeproduktion geht wo es um
die rohstoffe geht die für die industrie
notwendig sind ein teil der ölimporte
wird gar nicht fürs fahren oder heizen
benutzt sondern tatsächlich um chemische
produkte herzustellen
und deshalb kann man das nicht mit
dieser einen einfachen antwort überhaupt
lösen und die zweite antwort auf ihre
frage ist die technische wir haben
unsere atomkraftwerke darüber haben wir
aus gründen die ich sehr gut und richtig
finde und verändert entschieden dass wir
die auslaufen lassen wollen deswegen
aber auch ist auch nicht alles
vorbereitet für einen weiterbetrieb denn
das was wir gegenwärtig alle feststellen
es gibt ja nicht nur importe von kohle
gas und öl aus russland und einigen
anderen ländern das gilt ja auch für
kernbrennstäbe und für die physik ddd
nuklearen ressourcen die notwendig sind
das sind dinge die vorbereitet und
entschieden werden müssen wo man nicht
sagen kann ich tanke mal neu das ist
glaube ich ein technisches
missverständnisses eines atomkraftwerks
und deshalb ist das kein guter plan den
sie da insinuieren
sie können eine nachfrage stellen das
kannst du es ist natürlich schon so dass
wir ein großteil der kohle die momentan
eben zur verstromung eingesetzt wird der
steinkohle natürlich dadurch dann
ersetzen könnten dann müssten wir
weniger aus russland importieren also
von daher wäre es schon eine schnelle
lösung auf der anderen seite muss man ja
nur mal nachprüfen man kann nämlich eben
schon brennstoffe bestärkten stäbe
bestellen muss halt ein preisaufschlag
dafür bezahlen aber die unabhängigkeit
sollte es uns doch wert sein man kann
auch dafür sorgen dass zunächst einmal
kernkraftwerk im teillastbetrieb weiter
laufen damit sie eine gewisse
stromerzeugung eben machen man kann die
sicherheitsbedenken aus dem weg räumen
in dem das man im sommer eben runter
fährt die sicherheitsüberprüfung macht
so dass sie im winter zur verfügung
stehen und deswegen meine frage wie
viele lieferanten von brennstäben haben
sie denn angefragt und wie haben sie
denn und warum wurde die mögliche
sicherheitsüberprüfung der
kernkraftwerke im sommer bisher nicht
eingeplant als ist eine zeitenwende um
die frage noch einmal zu beantworten die
sie gestellt haben wenn man neue wenn
man die kernkraftwerke dauerhaft oder
eine längere zeit jetzt länger laufen
lassen will braucht man neuen
kernbrennstoff der nicht einfach
verfügbar ist er auch an technische
voraussetzungen gebundenes die nicht
über nacht hergestellt werden können und
deshalb haben sie ja selber das schon
ein bisschen berücksichtigt indem sie
vorschlagen man solle die atomkraftwerke
dieses jahr weniger laufen lassen damit
sie später mehr laufen können das ist
aber die antwort auf die frage gibt es
überhaupt genug auch sie gehen davon aus
offenbar nicht und deshalb ist es so
dass wir davon aber auch nichts hätten
denn wenn wir in diesem jahr ein mangel
haben an kohle gas oder
öl falls uns das passieren würde und wir
würden dann um das auszugleichen die
kern brennen die atomkraftwerke weniger
laufen lassen müssten wir mehr kohle gas
und öl verbrauchen das ist also die
milchmädchenrechnung von der ich am
anfang schon gesprochen habe es geht
einfach nicht aus was sich ausmachen
der nächste frage stelle als stephan
thome von der fdp-fraktion
viel lang frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler die beratungen auf
europäischer ebene über eine verteilung
der schutzsuchenden aus ukraine haben
leider keinen konsens über einen
verbindlichen verteilen mechanismus
geführt stattdessen ist ein freiwilliger
verteil index gefunden worden
freiwilligkeit etwas gutes aber eben
auch weniger verlässlich als
rechtsverbindliche verteil regeln und
niemand weiß und hilfsbereitschaft lange
anhält oder ob sie in künftigen fällen
auch wieder so groß ist wie in diesem
fall deswegen ist meine frage an sie ob
sich ihre bundesregierung mit dem
jetzigen freiwilligen verteilt
mechanismus zufrieden gibt oder ob sie
gleichwohl versuchen weiterhin einen
rechtsverbindlich verteidiger hindernis
muss für diesen künftige fälle zu
vereinbaren
zunächst mal ist es gut dass ganz europa
sich verantwortlich fühlt für die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen dass es mit
den entscheidungen die die europäische
union getroffen hat verbunden dass das
keine sache 19 länder ist dass alle
bereit sind ukrainische flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
eine entscheidung die wir in früheren
migrationsbewegung von flüchtlingen
nicht hatten und deshalb auch
wahrscheinlich ein
politischer wechsel eine politische
veränderung die weit über die
gegenwärtige herausforderung
hinausreicht trotzdem sind damit nicht
alle fragen gelöst werden und dann hatte
hatten und für einen festen gesetzlichen
gilt geltenden verteilen mechanismus hat
sich eben wie auch in der vergangenheit
keine mehrheit gefunden deshalb ist die
regelung die wir jetzt haben ein großer
fortschritt zu dem was wir in der
vergangenheit und was ich ihnen
versichern kann ist dass wir alles dafür
tun diese erklärte solidarität und
diesen mechanismus auch mit leben zu
erfüllen und in enger kooperation mit
den anderen europäischen ländern sieht
bitten sich an der aufnahme auf
verantwortung zu beteiligen
sie können einen anstellen wenn sie
erlauben eine nachfrage ich finde sie
sagen zu recht dass die qualität mit
flüchtlingen keine sache einzelner
länder ist so eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe
ganz europa vielleicht auch nicht nur
europa deswegen ist meine frage ob sie
auch in verbindung mit anderen
regierungen stehen etwa nordamerikas usa
kanadas ob auch diese länder falls der
zustrom lange anhalten sollte oder große
zahl von menschen weiterkommen sollte
auch diese länder bereit sind flüchtende
aufzunehmen die bereitschaft ist von
vielen erklärt worden die zahlen sind
natürlich
bisher nicht sehr groß die da real die
bewegung hin gefunden haben also das
fängt schon an mit unserem unmittelbaren
befreundeten nachbarn großbritannien
geht weiter bekannter da und die usa was
aber nicht nur an diesen ländern nicht
sondern auch an den ukrainischen
flüchtlingen selber die alle für sich
entschieden haben dass sie möglichst
dicht dran bleiben wollen an dem land
aus dem sie kommen weil er viele noch
die perspektive verfolgen dass sie auch
schnell wieder zurückkommen wollen
insofern wird sich das über die zeit
sicher ändern aber ich habe die
zusicherung von den regierungschefs
aller dieser drei länder die ich genannt
habe und noch manch anderer dass sie
sich darum bemühen werden und dass sie
aktiv an beitrag zur aufnahme leisten
wollen der kanadische premierminister
hat mir zum beispiel auch gesagt es habe
vor knapp 100 jahren nach kanada eine
massive ukrainische migration gegeben
die sehr dazu beigetragen habe dass
heutige kanada aufzubauen
deshalb geht er von einer großen
bereitschaft vieler bürgerinnen bürger
mit
verwandtschaftsverhältnissen in die
ukraine hinein aus auch hier einen
beitrag zu leisten
[Applaus]
die nächste frage stellt die kollegin
janine wissler aus der fraktion die
linke
herr bundeskanzler sie haben ja eben
noch einmal betont wie wichtig die
sanktionen gegen russland sind und gegen
die putin nahe stehenden oligarchen als
reaktion auf den angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine nun haben wir aber ja das
problem das in der praxis gerade die
sanktionen gegen die oligarchen in
deutschland besonders wirkungslos sind
also in deutschland sind ja nicht mal
100 millionen euro an geldern bisher
eingefroren worden 95 millionen um genau
zu sein allein in belgien war es mehr
als das hundertfache zehn milliarden
auch in frankreich und in italien ist es
ein vielfaches dieses betrages und
deshalb das problem scheint er hier zu
sein dass viel geld in briefkastenfirmen
versteckt wird auch in immobilien die
haben jetzt eine task force eingesetzt
um das problem zu beheben
und ich frage sie stimmen sie zu dass
dieses problem im wesentlichen umfang an
unzureichend ausgestatteten behörden
liegt wie das ja auch zollfahnder und
gewerkschafter öffentlich kritisiert
haben und gerade vor dem hintergrund
dass sie jahrelang als finanzminister
verantwortung getragen haben für den
bereich der geldwäsche wie schätzen sie
das ein und wie wollen sie dieses
problem lösen
zunächst einmal kann ich ihnen keine
auskunft geben über die gleiche
verteilung von in frage kommenden
vermögenswerten und personen in europa
da hat es ja auch unterschiedliche
praktiken gegeben sie kennen die debatte
über goldene wiesen und goldene pässe
sie kennen die praxis bestimmten
personen großartige lebensmöglichkeiten
den bestimmten metropolen zu verschaffen
da ist deutschland glaube ich eher
zurückhaltend gewesen um es sehr
freundlich zu sagen und hat nicht das
gleiche gemacht wie viele andere deshalb
wissen wir natürlich nicht ob alle
verhältnisse die aufzudecken sind
gewissermaßen überall gleich sind aber
die zweite frage ist völlig berechtigt
haben wir alle notwendigen instrumente
um aktiv so handeln zu können wie wir
das gerne wollen und die antwort darauf
lautet nein deshalb haben wir die task
force eingesetzt und deshalb haben wir
uns auch fest entschlossen schon im
koalitionsvertrag aber auch im hinblick
auf das was jetzt zu tun ist dass wir
alles dass wir etwas unternehmen wollen
um unsere handlungsmöglichkeiten zu
erhöhen und der plan der regierung ist
ein sanktionen durchsetzungs gesetz in
dem die verschiedenen gesetze die hier
berührt sind aufgegriffen werden und wir
ganz schnell uns alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten
verschaffen die wir brauchen um state of
the art handeln zu können
sie können eine nachfrage stellen herr
bundeskanzler will mich natürlich sehr
interessieren was sie planen in ihren
sanktionen durch das gesetz an konkreten
regelungsbedarf zu ändern und die
konkrete nachfrage gerade weil wir
wissen dass viel geld in immobilien
versteckt wird und es in deutschland
keine digitalen grundbücher gibt und
auch keine möglichkeit eben durch ein
zentrales immobilien register dies zu
erfassen meine frage an sie haben sich
als finanzminister dagegen verwehrt ein
solches immobilien register einzuführen
meine frage ist planen sie das jetzt wie
es heute ihre sicht auf die dinge jetzt
auch vor dem hintergrund dass eben die
sanktionen so schwer umgesetzt werden
können auch weil es einfach unklare
eigentümer strukturen im bereich der
immobilien gibt also sehen sie da heute
einen handlungsbedarf und was hat sie
damals dazu bewogen ein solches
zentrales immobilien register was ja
auch gefordert wurde aus gründen der
transparenz das damals abzulehnen das
was wir uns vorgenommen haben als
regierung wie sie dem koalitionsvertrag
der drei regierungsparteien und nehmen
können ist ja mein brands register das
ist eine weiterentwicklung des
vorhandenen so dass diese abfragen auch
möglich sind wir versuchen jetzt noch
weit über das was wir uns vorgenommen
hatten hinaus weitere
abfragemöglichkeiten und
suchmöglichkeiten zu schaffen und das
gleiche gilt im hinblick für die
hinblick auf die möglichkeit
abzugleichen
eigentümerstrukturen von grundbücher mit
den fragen die wir in so weit haben das
ist nicht nur ein rechtliches
unterfangen das wir haben so noch ein
großes technologisches unterfangen das
nicht von einem tag auf den anderen
bewältigt werden kann aber wir haben es
auf der agenda und verfolgen das mit
großem nachdruck nicht nur wegen der
aktuellen situation aber natürlich wegen
der unbedingt auch
den registern
[Applaus]
sie hatten die nachfrage schon dann ist
die nächste kolleginnen die eine frage
stellt ein update für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
den dank frau präsidentin sie hat
bundeskanzler hatten bereits im mai 2021
als damaliger finanzminister die idee
eines internationalen klima krebs
vorgestellt und diesen im rahmen des der
g7 g20
finanzminister innen diskutiert und im
august letzten jahres haben sie dann die
gemeinsame eckpunkte für einen
internationalen klima club in
bundeskabinett eingebracht und zunächst
möchte ich sie fragen welche bedeutung
dem klima kripp nach auffassung der
bundesregierung in der aktuellen lage
zukommt und außerdem möchte ich vor dem
hintergrund des zeitnah stattfinden
p g 7 gipfel tim in schloss elmau fragen
wie die bundesregierung den aktuellen
diskussionsstand innerhalb des g7
prozesses bewertet schönen dank für die
frage wir hatten das ja jetzt schon
verschiedenen seiten beleuchtet wenn wir
es schaffen wollen uns unabhängig macht
zu machen von dem passieren importen aus
russland wenn wir es schaffen es
hinzubekommen dass wir 2045 klimaneutral
wirtschaften können in deutschland dann
wird das auch eingebettet dann müssen
eine strategie die die ganze welt
verfolgt die ist nicht eins zu eins
gleich wie bei uns aber um die mitte des
jahrhunderts sollen entsprechende
fortschritte überall erreicht sein und
deshalb ist es notwendig dass all die
länder die vielleicht unterschiedliche
wege gehen aber das gleiche ziel
verfolgen das miteinander unter garten
können was keinen sinn macht es dass
jedes land seine eigenen maßregeln
schließt beschließt dann seine eigene
industrie mit zöllen oder grenz
ausgleich mechanismen oder sonstwas
beschützt und dann alle miteinander
kämpfen so diejenigen die in der
gleichen richtung unterwegs sind die
sollten sich zu verbünden zu einem
offenen klima club der für alle
zugänglich ist und in der deloitte
minded gewissermaßen den kampf gegen den
klimawandel auf nehmen angesichts der
tatsache dass das eine globale
herausforderung ist ist das ja erst
recht richtig wir haben das überall auf
die agenda gesetzt ob das nun g20 g7 die
oecd der internationale währungsfonds
oder die europäische union ist auch viel
unterstützung bekommen auch in den
entsprechenden beschlussfassung auch der
verschiedenen räte was europa betrifft
und für die g7 präsidentschaft
deutschland ist das einer der ganz
großen punkte die wir uns vorgenommen
haben ich sehe dass es dafür viel
unterstützung gibt und deshalb glaube
ich dass das auch zu den dingen gehört
die wir voranbringen können in unserer
präsidentschaft
[Applaus]
die beantwortung herzlichen dank dann
ist der nächste frage jürgen hart für
die cdu csu fraktion
dankeschön frau präsidentin lieber herr
bundeskanzler
ich muss leider auch das thema
waffenlieferung an die ukraine zu kommen
weil sie nach meiner auffassung den kern
der frage meines kollegen badekuren und
den kern der frage meines kollegen hahn
nicht beantwortet haben wir haben seit
wochen den wunsch der ukraine nach
panzerfahrzeugen schützenpanzern berge
panzern und so fort und wir wissen alle
dass diese panzer bei deutschen
rüstungsunternehmen und bei verwertung
von rüstungsgütern auf dem hof stehen
und bereits und zulieferung woran liegt
es dass diese wünsche der ukraine seit
wochen nicht geschieht werden können sie
mir versichern dass es nicht an der
bundesregierung liegt
schönen dank für ihre frage und ich will
das gerne noch mal sagen wir handeln in
der frage was wir exportieren was wir
möglich machen was wir finanzieren
abgestimmt mit unseren freunden und
verbündeten in der europäischen union
und der nato und all denjenigen die da
zusammen vorschläge haben wir betrachten
dies unter verschiedenen gesichtspunkten
dazu gehört aber ganz bestimmt dass wir
auf gleiche art und weise solche
militärische unterstützung liefern und
niemand vorprescht deutschland auch
nicht glaube dass das gerade hier um
eine frage geht bei der es ein schwerer
fehler wäre wenn deutschland eine
sonderrolle und ein sonderweg
einschlagen würde ich glaube dass sie
dafür großes verständnis haben und
deshalb gehört es natürlich im übrigen
auch immer dazu dass wir bei allem was
wir konkret zu bewerten haben in den
zuständigen gremien auch uns genau
anschauen wann bestimmte dinge überhaupt
verfügbar sind welche qualität sie haben
und wird glaube ich sollten ja auch uns
vor vorwürfen schützen dass wir dinge
liefern die keinen militärischen nutzen
haben
er hat ziehen möchten eine nachhaltig
schön herr bundeskanzler jetzt hat
tschechien angekündigt schützenpanzer zu
liefern tschechien ist ja eine eu
partner würden sie dies als verbrechen
kritisieren das ist eine international
abgestimmte
handlungsweise bei der auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland eine wichtige
rolle spielt weil es sich um sehr alte
bestände aus der die deutscher denn da
infrage nutzt worden sind handelt die
aber den vorzug haben dass sie in diesem
zusammenhang ganz besonders gut
eingesetzt werden können in
der ukraine weil sie dort auch ansonsten
erfahrung mit diesen geräten haben das
gehört ja auch dazu dass wir immer
geräte liefern müssen die auch
eingesetzt werden können
die nächste frage stellt die kollegin
renate künast
frau präsidentin herr bundeskanzler
es geht mir um versorgungssicherheit mit
lebensmittel wie beurteilen sie die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland und
europa im augenblick und mittelfristig
welche maßnahmen halten sie für nötig
werde man zusammen denkt den angriff auf
die ukraine und den bedarf dort die
klima und die biodiversitäts krise
die fragen gehört sind natürlich sehr
groß bin ich das sagen darf ich will
versuchen sie für die kurze zeit zu
beantworten die mir zur verfügung so
kurz zu beantworten wie sie zur
verfügung steht
wir müssen wir können in europa sicher
der versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten
wir haben handlungsmöglichkeiten die
auch genutzt werden in der eu genutzt
worden sind das hat sich auch der
landwirtschaftsminister sie eingesetzt
dass das möglich wird aber wir müssen
uns viel mehr und viel größere sorgen
machen im hinblick auf die
versorgungssicherheit für die übrige
welt denn wir wissen dass die ukraine
und aus russland große exporteure von
heizen zum beispiel sind und für die
ernährungssicherheit vieler länder der
welt eine rolle spielen dieser krieg
stellt das in frage und gefährdet das
und darum ist es sehr wichtig dass der
landwirtschaftsminister aber auch die
entwicklungshilfe ministerin alles dafür
tun dass wir unsere verantwortung für
die sicherheit der
lebensmittelversorgung vieler bürgern
und bürger auf unserem planeten mit
übernehmen durch förderprogramme durch
absprachen durch kooperation und das
gehört zu unserer politik
fragten das haben sie einen
sie haben herr bundeskanzler ja
angesprochen welche zusammenhänge wie
erkennen wir haben ja selber durch die
pandemie und durch die ukraine krise
noch mal gesehen in wie vielen bereichen
wir uns fälschlicherweise abhängig
gemacht haben erst bei den masken
und kitteln die wir nur an einer stelle
hatten bei der energiewende abhängig
gemacht und wir sehen heute auch das
festlich wir aber andere staaten sie in
afrika sich sehr abhängig gemacht haben
vom weizen zb oder mais an der stelle
und manche diskutiert deshalb heute dass
wir alles was an europäische agrarreform
auf den weg gebracht wurde stoppen
müssen deshalb frage ich sie unterstützt
die bundesregierung weiterhin die eu
kommission beim green deal bei farb tv
und all den versuchen wirklich
nachhaltige landwirtschaft bei uns aber
auch in anderen ländern aufzubauen damit
sie sich selbst besser ernähren können
sicher werden wir das tun ich habe ja
bereits berichtet dass das gut abgewogen
entschieden worden ist von der
europäischen union aber auch von der
bundesregierung unterstützt indem wir
ein bisschen möglichkeiten geschaffen
haben zb für futterpflanzen und
ähnliches aber eben das so abgewogen
gemacht haben dass die anderen
zielsetzung die wir verfolgen darüber
nicht in gefahr geraten
[Applaus]
der kollege dr gottfried kurios die
nächste frage
herr bundeskanzler der
bundesnachrichtendienst warnt vor
schleuser netzwerken die die
fluchtbewegung aus der ukraine ausnutzen
möglicherweise wurde die lager auch von
mitgliedern terroristischer
gruppierungen genutzt erkenntnissen der
behörde zufolge mischen sich jetzt unter
die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine auch
ganz andere migranten aus der balkan und
ostroute und schleuser fashion gezielt
ukrainische personaldokumente bieten die
im netz an gleichzeitig sagt die
deutsche polizeigewerkschaft es wenn
überhaupt nur 60 prozent der flüchtlinge
kontrolliert sind vor diesem hintergrund
dennoch auch sie wie die innenministerin
nicht willens bei den
grenzüberschreitungen für eine
vollständige und täuschung stream samt
erkennungsdienstliche erfassung der
identität zu sorgen und nehmen also
durch diese verweigerung folgten der
kontrolle die 2015 sehenden auges die
betrugsfälle und die sicherheitsrisiken
für deutschland in kauf
es ist nicht richtig was ihren ihrer
frage unterstellen es wird sehr
umfassend kontrolliert und identifiziert
wir machen das ganz besonders für
diejenigen die nicht über ukrainische
pässe verfügen und mittelbar auch bei
den verschiedenen einreisen das machen
wir auch unsere nachbarn so die da auch
ein beitrag leisten und enger
kooperation mit denen gelingt das auch
und gleichzeitig sorgen wir dafür dass
alle diejenigen die hier bei uns einen
auf halt anstreben und von den
möglichkeiten gebrauch machen die die
europäische union wir und viele andere
länder geschaffen haben sich auch melden
müssen dass sie registriert werden im
ausländerzentralregister dass wir massiv
modernisiert haben in den letzten jahren
und dass uns die möglichkeit gibt
gleichzeitig alle personen nicht nur
konkret anhand biometrischer daten zu
identifizieren sondern auch
datenbankabfragen zu machen die es uns
in die lage versetzen auch diejenigen
heraus zu finden die sich darunter
mischen wollen oder gegen die etwas
vorliegt was wir nicht akzeptieren kann
herr dr haben sie eine nachfrage des
bundesnachrichtendienstes
polizeigewerkschaft sehen dass weit
weniger entspannt da werden also die von
den sicherheitsbehörden erwartet um
gefahr nicht wirklich verhindert und
illegale nicht schutz wird der mandanten
unter den wirklichen flüchtlingen jetzt
quasi versteckt auch die schon im
februar vor kriegsbeginn explodierenden
energiepreise werden ja jetzt auf kriegs
verursacht umgedeutet und in der ukraine
krise versteckt wollen sie die warenhaus
gemachten gründe für den
wirtschaftlichen niedergang deutschlands
missmanagement energiewende gelddrucken
schulden euro verstecken in den folgen
von krieg und unnötigen sanktionen
glauben sie dass die bürger auf diese
umdeutung
hereinfallen ich hoffe dass in ihren
social media programm nicht nur ihre
fragen sondern auch meine antworten
abgebildet werden
ich habe manchmal den eindruck sie
stellen fragen die gar nicht darauf aus
sind dass man noch eine antwort gibt
aber ich gebe ihnen trotzdem eine es
stimmt einfach nicht was sie sagen
deutschland ist das eines der
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten länder
der welt einer der großen gewinner der
globalisierung technologisch weltweit an
der spitze und das wird zu bleiben
markus herb und hat die nächste frage
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter bundeskanzler ich möchte auch
auf die inflation zu sprechen kommen sie
wurde von vielen und wird von vielen
unterschätzt so wohl dass die dauer
angeht als auch was die höhe angeht der
staat nimmt seit jahren einen ausgleich
ob darauf vor dass staatseinnahmen nur
deshalb steigen weil eine inflation
vorhanden ist stichwort kalte
progression meine frage da lautet können
sie abschätzen wann der bericht zur
kalten progression kommt und inwiefern
damit die umsetzung dieser inflation
ausgeglichen ausgeglichen wird wir haben
ja jetzt schon eine ganze reihe von
maßnahmen ergriffen um auf diese
herausforderung mit den steigenden
preisen zu reagieren dazu gehören
insbesondere massive steuerliche
entlastungen die sich für alle
nützlich werden ganz besonders für die
ihnen die wenig verdienen aber natürlich
auch für viele andere mit der höheren
arbeitnehmerpauschale mit dem höheren
grundfreibetrag und verschiedenen
anderen entscheidungen über die fohlen
schon berichten konnte aber klar ist es
gibt immer wieder auch erneut an bericht
über die kalte progression und ihre
auswirkung und wenn ich es richtig im
kopf habe ist er für diesen herbst
geplant
frage ich habe noch eine nachfrage teile
ihre auffassung dass die möglichkeiten
des staates darauf zu reagieren auf die
inflation das sind entlastungen die
vorgenommen werden
das cola steuer hilfe gesetz ist im
parlamentarischen verfahren das erste
entlastungspaket auch können sie konkret
benennen wann das zweite
entlastungspaket wirkt wir arbeiten
nicht final an schritten und ist ja
alles noch vor sommer der sommerpause
von ihnen durch dieses parlament
befördert werde nicht mehr auf ihre
unterstützung
christian görke ist der nächste fragende
für die linke
jetzt vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler
das thema explosion der energiepreise
spekulationsgewinne war ja schon thema
in dieser stunde jetzt hat die
europäische kommission im märz den
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten die
möglichkeit eröffnet diese sogenannten
zufalls gewinne diese
spekulationsgewinne zu besteuern und die
europäische energie agentur geht davon
aus dass erlöse bis zu 200 milliarden
euro in der europäischen union in diesem
jahr besteuert werden könnten deshalb
frage ich sie welchen diskussionsstand
gibt es in der bundesregierung und vor
allen dingen welche persönliche position
haben sie dazu um diese diesen
übermäßigen krisen gewinne gerecht zu
besteuern
zunächst mal werden alle gewinne
besteuert auch übermäßige riesengewinne
das gehört zu unserer steuer ordnung
dazu und es geht ja nicht darum steuern
überhaupt erst mal neu zu entwickeln die
besteuerung muss ja sowieso erfolgen und
gleichzeitig ist unser gegenwärtiges
bemühen vor allem darauf gerichtet wie
wir die übermäßige steigerung der
energiepreise
reduzieren können weil das natürlich
eine herausforderung ist die für die
sich stellt und die man nicht einfach
beamten einfach so da lassen kann wie
sie ist klar ist ein großer teil der
steigenden preise hat etwas zu tun mit
herausforderungen die außerhalb europas
liegen die großen krisenbekämpfung
programme am ende der kroner pandemie
haben dazu beigetragen dass überall
preise gestiegen sind nachfrage auch
nach ressourcen und nach verschiedenen
produkten größer geworden ist und
deshalb auch die preise gestiegen sind
die großen herausforderung für die
logistikketten in der welt haben auch
preissteigerung verursacht die sich
massiv bemerkbar machen und ich gehe
davon aus dass die globalisierung ein
ende nimmt im hinblick auf die phase wo
alles sehr billig war weil nur ein
kleiner teil des marktes bedingt wurde
von der ganzen übrigen welt der
fortschritt der letzten 30 40 jahre war
auch dass viele andere länder der welt
soweit aufgeschlossen sind das jetzt als
nachfrage auf diesem markt auch mit uns
um knappe güter konkurrieren mit den
konsequenzen
all das sind ja erst mal höhere preise
ohne höhere gewinnen ansonsten schauen
wir uns alles genau
haben wir einen das ist schön dass sich
alles genau anschauen ich hatte so den
eindruck dass sie sich jetzt um eine
antwort herummogeln deshalb vielleicht
noch mal die frage meinen sie nicht auch
dass ihr regierungskollege mario draghi
in italien konservativer kein linker der
dieses instrumenten nutzte nicht ein
beispiel auch für die bundesrepublik
deutschland und für sie als
bundeskanzler sein könnte
ich halte mich sehr oft und sehr gern
mit meinem kollegen draghi der wirklich
ein sehr kluger mann ist und es
geschafft hat eine gute politische
richtung in italien zu etablieren wir
alle kämpfen mit den herausforderungen
tannen sind die besonders weil zum
beispiel die abhängigkeit vom gast ob
noch viel größer ist als das bei uns der
fall ist und die möglichkeiten mit
dieser situation umzugehen viel kleiner
sind als bei uns deshalb haben wir den
vielen debatten die wir jetzt in europa
geführt haben schon festgestellt es wird
nicht ganz einfach seien alle 27 länder
über einen kamm zu scheren weil es
einfach ganz unterschiedliche töpfe sind
und das zweite ist dass wir ganz klar
machen dass wir
dann aber abgestimmte politik entwickeln
müssen das ist noch nicht zu ende
darüber reden wir miteinander und einer
meiner besten gesprächspartner ist der
italienische ministerpräsident
was die rosemann stellt die nächste
frage
vielen dank frau präsidentin der
bundeskanzler im
koalitionsvertrag der von ihnen
geführten fortschritts koalition
finden sich ja unter dem der überschrift
respekt und sozialer fortschritt eine
ganze reihe von vorhaben die erhöhung
des gesetzlichen mindestlohns auf 12
euro haben sie vorhin schon angesprochen
dazu kommen projekte wie die
kindergrundsicherung die einführung des
bürgergeldes die stabilisierung der
rente
verbesserungen für die
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und
erwerbsminderungsrentner der
bundeskanzler ich möchte sie fragen
welche bedeutung und welchen stellenwert
messen sie diesen projekten angesichts
der derzeitigen weltpolitischen
situation und ihrer auswirkungen auf
die situation in deutschland zu
das ist ziemlich klar dass wir vor
großen herausforderungen stehen
angesichts der des krieges russlands
gegen die ukraine angesichts der großen
verwerfungen die wir auf den
weltenergiemärkten sehen und viele
andere herausforderung die wir heute
schon sorgfältig besprochen haben
auch angesichts der notwendigkeit dafür
zu sorgen dass wir wegen der russischen
aggression
sicherstellen müssen dass die nato und
auch die bundeswehr gut ausgestattet
sind und deshalb werden wir dazu auch
mehr mittel mobilisieren müssen sie
wissen und kennen mein wissen mein
vorschlag mit dem sondervermögen
bundeswehr aber gerade deshalb ist mir
wichtig zu betonen
diese vorhaben von denen sie einige
aufgezählt haben und die liste ließe
sich verlängern
unverändert fortgesetzt werden aus
meiner sicht sind sie jetzt es recht
notwendig denn wenn eine gesellschaft
durch so schwierige zeiten geht dann
muss sie zusammenhalten und diese
vorhaben gegen den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft und dass es gerecht zugeht
[Applaus]
der bundeskanzler sie haben die
finanzierung angesprochen und ich möchte
sie deshalb fragen können sie
sicherstellen dass die finanzierung der
genannten projekte
gesichert ist dass diese projekte wie im
koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen
tatsächlich realisiert werden können und
auch finanziell in den kommenden jahren
entsprechend hinterlegt werden
das ist das was wir uns miteinander
vorgenommen haben und deshalb kann ich
versichern dass die täter der regierung
der finanzminister genauso wie arbeits
und sozialminister zum beispiel oder die
familienministerin der festen
überzeugung sind diese dinge gehören zu
dem gesamten vorhaben dazu dass wir uns
für dieses land vorgenommen haben und
wir halten ihn unverändert fest
herzlich dankt ich ende damit die
befragung des bundeskanzlers und bedanke
mich bei allen beteiligten jetzt hoffe
ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkten ich diesen
tagesordnungspunkt meine damen und
herren mit dem beschäftigen wir uns erst
mal nicht weil ja auch ein bisschen
kompliziert zu übertragen ist die
befragung der bundesregierung in diesem
fall des bundeskanzlers ist so ende
nicht immer hat er zur zufriedenheit der
abgeordneten beantwortet heute aber so
kennen ihn ja die allermeisten auch
insbesondere bei heiklen themen hat sich
olaf scholz wie gewohnt etwas
zurückgehalten
und da wird der wahrscheinlich bei
nächster gelegenheit die eine und andere
nachfrage noch bekommen es drehte sich
hier logischerweise überwiegend um den
krieg gegen die ukraine und die frage
wie deutschland auf verschiedenen ebenen
ebenen darin involviert ist es wird hier
zu diesem thema krieg gegen die ukraine
um circa 15 uhr 515 so ganz genau lässt
sich das nicht vorhersagen eine aktuelle
stunde geben die hat die koalition hier
beantragt und der titel ist massaker der
russischen truppen einen ukrainischen
zivilisten ihnen botschaft dass also wie
gesagt 5 nach 3 wahrscheinlich jahrzehnt
oder auch viertel nach drei bleiben sie
am besten so oder so bei uns wir sind
dann live wieder hier im deutschen
bundestag ich gebe 121 zurück zu hans
werner fittkau in bonn
vielen dank erhard scherfer und bis ca
10 oder viertel nach drei haben wir für
sie aktuelle informationen
zunächst natürlich zum krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine ist